merci cher bruno je suis victime moi
même des coupes budgétaires de parole
puisque on m'a demandé de raccourcir mon
propos et je vais donc vous et je vais
donc essayer de vous démontrer la
capacité de synthèse d'un avocat ce qui
est souvent ce qui est souvent
controversées cher bruno puisqu'il
s'agissait de réfléchir à un programme
je viens vers vous avec cette
proposition cette proposition
d'évolution de législation sur la
légitime défense qui pour la plupart
concernent les forces de l'ordre mais
qui pour les deux dernières peuvent
également s'appliquer aux citoyens juste
pour que chacun sache de quoi on parle
il faut que vous sachiez qu'aujourd'hui
en droit français le droit à
l'utilisation légitime de la violence
est exactement le même pour les citoyens
c'est à dire pour vous tous dans la
salle que pour les soldats pour les
policiers pour les policiers d'élite
face au terrorisme etc
nous sommes face à une situation qui est
juridiquement aberrante d'autant plus
qu'elle est aujourd'hui utilisé par des
magistrats qui sont totalement
déconnectés face aux réalités de
l'augmentation de la violence auxquels
sont confrontés notamment nos forces de
l'ordre mais également nous tous
citoyens puisque comme vous le savez la
délinquance violente a considérablement
augmenté ces dernières années
cette proposition on y va les trois
premières sont des propositions sur la
réaffectation et des changements à la
fois juridique et psychologique sur la
façon d'utiliser nos forces de l'ordre
le premier on sait que et charlie
l'hyper cacher villejuif le thalys le
concert de rock on en a moins parlé mais
il ya un attentat qui a été déjoué
contre un concert de rock
on sait qu'aujourd'hui la france est
l'objet et sera l'objet d' attaque et
d'attac de ce qu'on appelle des tueurs
de masse c'est-à-dire des gens qui vont
tirer dans la foule on sait par le
retour d'expérience dans le monde entier
que le nombre de victimes est
proportionnel au temps que mettent les
primes aux intervenants c'est à dire les
gens qui vont pouvoir riposter
arrivé sur la scène l'exemple israéliens
nous montre que le meilleur façon de
faire c'est d'avoir en permanence des
gens sur place keufer on peut pas mettre
des policiers partout
la réponse est extrêmement simple mais
pour ça il faut totalement changé notre
adn sur la question c'est qu'il faut
qu'ils aient des gens armés dans les
lieux publics en permanence qui seraient
ces gens armés sur les lieux publics en
permanence tout simplement les membres
des forces de l'ordre et je les écris
avec patrice ribeiro dans votre
successeur à synergie dans le figaro au
mois de septembre
faut non seulement autorisé mais
encouragé toutes les personnes
légalement à voir mais à porter une arme
en france à la porte et même en dehors
de leurs heures de service en civil
quand ils vont au supermarché quand ils
vont au centre commercial quand ils vont
au cinéma quand ils vont dans les gares
c'est comme ça qu'on aura la chance
statistiques c'est comme ça qu'on aura
la chance statistiques de voir un
citoyen français devaient revenus
citoyens parce que policier hors service
ou parce que transporteur de fonds hors
service s'opposer à un terroriste dans
un centre commercial où dans une gare ça
c'est la première proposition
la deuxième les primes aux intervenants
policiers proprement dit le raid le gign
labeyrie les unités spécialisées ne sont
pas là lorsqu'un attentat
il faut qu'elle arrive avant qu'elles
arrivent les premiers qui viennent c'est
la sécurité publique donc en zone police
et les agents de police secours est en
zone gendarmerie c'est la gendarmerie
territoriale
il faut donner à ses agents les moyens
de l'équipement notamment avec des armes
longues et d'entraînement qui va avec
pour pouvoir être efficace
ils ne sont évidemment pas du tout
formés aujourd'hui à cela troisième
proposition
je rejoins tiers brajeux il faut
évidemment soulagé les missions des
forces de l'ordre que ce soit la police
ou l'armée qui aujourd'hui font
notamment des milieux des missions de
protection de sécurisation de zone en
les confiant à des sociétés privées
agréées en armant ses sociétés privées
agréées évidemment pas n'importe comment
avec des protocoles de contrôle mais il
ya beaucoup d'anciens militaires très
qualifiés très compétents qui pourraient
remplir ses missions sur des points
fixes et notamment sur les zones
industrielles de type seveso
ce qui permettrait de dégager des
milliers d'emplois de policiers et de
gendarmes et de deux militaires pour
être affectés à des missions relevant
plus directement de leurs compétences
quatrième proposition j'en viens
maintenant ce qui concerne la légitime
défense au sens strict vous savez tous
aujourd'hui citoyen ou policiers l'acte
de violence légitime doit être immédiat
c'est à dire qu'il faut que ce soit au
sens étroit du terme au moment de
l'agression et surtout doit être
proportionnée c'est à dire qu'on exige
d'eux celui qui est surpris de celui qui
vaque à ses occupations d'avoir la
lucidité et la vertu alors qu'il est
exposé et soudain un risque de mort
imminent d'être capable de doser sa
réplique face à un voyou face à un
terreau
rist qui lui al avantage stratégique
c'est-à-dire qu'il a choisi son moment
ses moyens et et son lieu donc tout ça
est totalement déconnectée de la réalité
et pour ce faire quatre propositions
vous voyez chers bruno que j'essaie
d'avancer de façon structurée et rapide
ma part ma première propre dans 45
ma première proposition avec le syndicat
des commissaires de la police nationale
la création d'une période de danger
absolu une pda on l'a appelé comme ça on
peut l'appeler autrement
qu'est ce que ce serait que la pda la
pda ce serait que en fonction de
critères objectifs tels que par exemple
la perceuse la présence d'armes de
guerre dans une zone civile que à partir
du moment où cette présence est détecté
jusqu'à ce que l'autorité décide que la
pda est terminée les forces de l'ordre
et des règles d'engagement qui change
avec notamment la possibilité d'ouvrir
le feu non seulement sur des gens qui
les visent directement mais également
sur des gens qui sont mobiles pour les
fixer
c'est des termes militaires que je vais
employer mais pour faire des tirs de
fixation et des tirs d'interdiction de
façon à permettre de figer une situation
et à permettre la tante up efficace et
l'arrivée des unités spécialisées
il faut également que dans cette pda on
puisse tirer dans le dos je dis bien
tiré dans le dos de terroristes qui
quitteraient une scène en mettant leurs
kalachnikov dans une voiture est en
partance et on sait très bien qu'ils ne
vont pas partir pour partir en vacances
et cesser leurs actes de délinquance
on est nous sommes dans une situation
que tout le monde a identifié que tout
le monde a identifié comme une situation
de guerre et il faut que nos forces de
l'ordre et les moyens juridiques de
faire face à sète à cette situation la
quatrième proposition est un dérivé de
la troisième je la passe et j'en viens
aux deux dernières qui sont beaucoup
plus large et qui concernerait tous les
citoyens je pense que par rapport à
l'augmentation et à la violence de la
délinquance notamment dans les domiciles
il faut créer une présomption de
légitime défense qui existe déjà de nuit
mais qui a été dénaturée par la
jurisprudence 24 heures sur 24 dans les
domiciles mon raisonnement est très
simple si un voyou arrive chez vous vous
n'êtes pas obligé d'attendre de voir
s'il va juste piqué la télé ce qui est
un délit ou s'il va en plus dû aller
votre femme et vous torturer pour le
code de la carte bleue ce qui est un
crime
pour savoir si vous pouvez vous défendre
je veux
une présomption de légitime défense dans
les domiciles et ma dernière est ma
dernière proposition je n'ai aucun
mérite
il faut l'appliquer au suisse les
suisses ont un article 33
dans leur code pénal qui est un article
de bon sens il ya beaucoup de bon sens
dans le droit suisse et qui dit la chose
suivante si celui qui repousse une
attaque a excédé les bornes de la
légitime défense
le juge atténuera librement la peine si
cet excès provient d'un état excusable
d'excitation ou de saisissement causés
par la tacc aucune peine ne sera
encourus il est temps que notre droit
positif à la fois pour les forces de
l'ordre mais aussi pour les citoyens
prennent en compte notre monde qui
change prennent en compte le fait que
notre pays est attaqué et que par
ailleurs nous avons une délinquance
hyper violente et permettre aux gens
qu'ils soient civils ou qu'ils soient
dans les forces de l'ordre de s'en
sortir sans ensuite le payer
juridiquement toute leur vie merci